- You know, I'm concerned a little bit
with the culture of
celebrating the fund raise.
You know, my dad taught me
that when you borrow money
it's the worst day of your life.
So I'm very interested
in the entrepreneurs.
I like you know, we
didn't clap for Red Rover
because they didn't raise
six trillion dollars.
But I was sitting here like good stuff.
I just filtered myself, so.
(laughter)
You know, what I'm looking
for is people that are not
caught up in the excitement.
Even though I'm a hype man myself,
I like the practicality of it all,
people that understand
how to turn a profit.
I mean, at the end of the day
this is still business, right?
So I'm looking for real
practical knowledge
of how to actually make money,
not necessarily raise it.
(techno music)